So let's look at edge detection with a simple example.
I'm going to give you my usual, simple image.
Let's use this as an example, and see what we can do with it.
So the basic idea of edge detection is, we want to look for
a neighborhood with strong signs of change.
So let's, for example, look at this pixel, or this neighborhood of one,
and look at it with respect to the other pixels around it.
How much is the change from here to there?
How much is the change from here to here and
also basically just in that neighborhood of these pixels here, figure out,
oh is there a big discontinuity here?
And of course, there is a significant discontinuity 12 intensity to 90.
We can basically start looking at that one by one throughout the whole image, so
of course the same when I look at this.
And I compare it with this.
There's a discontinuity, a significant one between these two.
However, not much so between 90 and 89.
Looking at this pixel here, I would also, also have the same type of comparison.
Much more discontinuity here.
Of course, I didn't go down all the way here, but
if you notice, 89, 86, 87, 82 were somewhat similar.
Not exactly the same.
I mean there is discontinuity, just not a significant one.
But between 12 and 88 much more.
Again we can keep coming down this way.
And 9 and 10 have discontinuity, 15 and 12 have discontinuity, but small.
So [INAUDIBLE] when I hit 12,
you basically notice a significant discontinuity here.
And also between 12 and 84.
So this process basically as a scan through an image.
I will be looking for each and every pixel and
look in the neighborhood, the four connected next to it itself and say,
okay, do I need to put something between those pixels to create an edge?
And I can just go through the whole process and see how this looks for
this instance, and you can basically see that, of course, just by looking at
a contin, discontinuities between different types of things, we can create
this simple, line, which separates out this part of the image with that one.
Or basically points out that there is a discontinuity between it.
Here is another way of looking at it.
Basically, now I've just given those gray values and
now I can see the edge between the two.
Becomes much more clearer this way also.
So as we do this, we have to think about various things.
What is the size of the neighborhood?
I started off with basically the assumption that the neighborhood size.
Which I've always referred to was one because I look at it with respect to that.
Then also what metric represents a change?
And in this case we looked at saying is, well let's not basically think they
are different if the pixel intensity's different by three.
But if it's several orders of in this case, of course, almost 78,
we would put that as an edge.
Or, in this case, you know, again, about 76,
so all of those radiations are much larger.
So we basically came up with some sort of a threshold, and
defined that as where we want to actually look for those changes.
If there was with certain amounts, if it was above it or
not, we would actually look for that discontinuity.
Of course there is discontinuity, much smaller one between each and every pixel.
But we will just be looking for larger ones.
So that's one more thing we have to look at.